>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Travis Hensley: Good
afternoon everyone.
My name is Travis Hensley.
I'm a program specialist here
at the John W. Kluge Center.
Just a few quick announcements.
First of all, I'd
like to ask you all
to please put your
phone on silent.
And I also want to let you
know that this is being filmed
for broadcast on
CSPAN History TV
and the Library of
Congress' website.
It is my pleasure to introduce
acting deputy librarian
of Congress, Mark Sweeney.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Sweeney: Thank
you, and good afternoon,
and welcome to the
Library of Congress.
It's my pleasure to welcome you
to the Library's historic
Thomas Jefferson Building
and this afternoon symposium
1619 in the Making of America,
which is being hosted by the
John W. Kluge Center here
at the Library of Congress.
The Kluge Center was
founded in 2000 in order
to foster the mutually enriching
relationship between scholars
and political leaders.
The Kluge Center
attracts to Washington,
the best minds available
in the scholarly world.
Facilitates their access to
the Library's rich, diverse
and enduring source
of knowledge.
And engages them in conversation
with the US Congress
and other political figures.
Today's symposium is being
held in collaboration
with the Middle Passage Project
of the College of William
and Mary, Norfolk
State University
and the Virginia Commonwealth's
2019 Commemoration.
Founded in 1995, the Middle
Passage Project explores the
history and memory surrounding
the Transatlantic slave trade,
its resounding effects on
Africans in the Americas
and its representation
in literature,
the humanities, art and history.
1619 was a pivotal year
in America's history
and marks the arrival
of the first Africans
to English North
America, the establishment
of the first permanent
English colony in North America
at Jamestown, Virginia, and the
first representative legislative
assembly in the new world
with the founding of the House
of House of Burgesses.
This symposium will explore
the intricate encounters
of Africans, Europeans
and Native peoples during
this significant period.
Who are the Africans that
arrived in Jamestown in 1619?
Where did they come from?
What world did they
bring with them?
What emerged from the
Africans' engagement
with indigenous Native American
populations and their spiritual
and cultural life ways?
And what is the enduring
legacy of this encounter today?
So many questions that we can
have answered, hopefully, today.
Today's program will promote
historical accessibility
to the meaning of 1619
and lay the groundwork
for a national dialogue
and renewed understanding
of the major events that
began 400 years ago.
Lastly, our curators here
at the Library have
prepared a special treat
for you this afternoon.
They've assembled a display of
treasures and historical items
from the Library's collections
related to the early Americas,
and I invite you to explore them
in the other room there
after the program.
And now let me turn this
over to today's convener,
the 2015 Larsen Fellow in
Health and Spirituality
at the John W. Kluge
Center and the director
of The Middle Passage
Project, Dr. Joanne Braxton.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Joanne M. Braxton: Thank you
for that warm welcome, Mark.
It's good to be here.
On behalf of The
Middle Passage Project,
the Joseph Jenkins Roberts
Institute for Africana Studies
at Norfolk State University
International Programs,
the Virginia Historical
Foundation for the Humanities,
the College of William &
Mary's 1619 project initiative,
our lemon project and
the Nottoway Indian Tribe
of Virginia and especially
the 2019 Commemoration
American Evolution.
I thank you for making
us welcome here today
at the John W. Kluge Center.
And we would also like to add
our welcome, our warm welcome
to everyone who has come
out today, not only to hear,
but to engage and participate
in what we hope will be a
transformative conversation.
I would like to give a special
thank you to Travis Hensley
of the Library of
Congress Office
of Scholarly Programs
Kluge Center
for seeing the significance of
today's symposium and exhibition
and supporting it with
enthusiasm and gusto
over a period of time.
[ Applause ]
We all love Travis.
We hope that this conversation
will lay the groundwork
for a national dialogue and
reinterpretation of major events
that began in 1619 that
would shape the contours
and character of America today.
This event is part
of a larger project
of 2019 commemoration
American Evolution
that will bring programs, events
and scholarly conversations
to the Commonwealth of
Virginia and the nation
in the next two years
as we examine 400 years
of American history in Virginia.
Our speakers today are
Professor Robert Trent Vinson
of the College of
William & Mary,
Professor Cassandra
Newby-Alexander
of Norfolk State University,
Chief Lynette Allston
of the Nottoway Indian tribe
of Virginia, Incorporated
and myself, Joanne Braxton.
You have our bios
in your program,
so I will spare you
reading the biographies.
Our presentations today will
range from the scholarly
and the historical to
informed personal reflections.
And again, there will
be a time for engagement
as indicated on your program.
So, without further ado, I would
welcome Robert Trent Vinson,
my esteemed colleague.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert Trent Vinson:
Thank you, Dr. Braxton.
Thank you to the Kluge Center.
There are many, many
thanks to give.
I have limited time,
and academics are
notoriously long-winded.
So I could take up all my time
by giving thanks to everyone.
So, thank you to everyone.
So my job here is to talk a bit
about the African background
and the Transatlantic journeys
of the 1619, 20 and odd Negroes
that arrived at Point
Comfort, Virginia.
Point Comfort, which
is now Hampton.
Right near the fledgling
Jamestown settlement in 1619.
Who were they?
Where did they come from?
And what was their experience?
What might their
experience have been as best
as we can reconstruct it?
In August 1619, a captive woman
named Angela, part of those 20
and odd Africans that
landed at Point Comfort,
arrived traumatized, mentally,
emotionally and physically,
that endured a long journey
of months from their homes
in West Central Africa.
They likely came from the
West Central African states
of Congo and Ndongo.
If you take a look at
the map to the left here,
you'll see this region
of West Central Africa,
and you'll see Congo, and
you'll also see Ndongo
in this area here.
I hope everyone can see okay.
And you'll also notice
the word Luanda,
which will be the capital of a
Portuguese colony called Angola.
So those are our three major
points that I'll refer to.
Of course, the 1619 Africans
were not the first time
that Africans had arrived
in the Western Hemisphere.
By the time Angela and her
fellow captors had arrived,
about 500,000 enslaved
Africans had already gone
on a transatlantic journey
from the West Coast of Africa
into the Americas, primarily in
Spanish colonies in the Americas
and the Portuguese
colony of Brazil.
They came from densely
settled urban towns.
Some came from rural villages
where they would have
raised agricultural crops
like sorghum and millet.
Some might have tended
livestock including cattle.
And interestingly enough, if
you notice their names, Angela,
Pedro, Peter, some featured
Iberian and Christian names.
And that is indicative of
the fact that in this area,
particularly in Congo, there had
been a longstanding engagement
with Christianity
and with Portugal.
Congo, in particular, was
a strong political state
that maintained close
diplomatic, economic
and cultural ties with Portugal.
With Portuguese Catholic
missionaries and traders
in Congo and Congolese
royal ambassadors
and other emissaries
going to Portugal starting
in the 15th century continuing
through the 16th century.
By 1491, Congolese royalty
declared Christianity
to be a state religion.
But this was controlled
by the Congolese.
So it's not an imposition
by the Portuguese,
but this was Congolese engaging
in Christianity and using
that to start Congolese-run
Christian schools.
They were literate people
who spoke the closely
related languages
of Kikongo and Kimbundu.
Some also spoke Portuguese.
And by 1595, the papacy
in Rome had declared Congo
to be its own Episcopal
district,
and its primary church
became a cathedral.
Christianity also impacted in
the state of Ndongo as well.
So, the names are indicative
of this engagement
with Christianity.
Now, though Congo had
exported enslaved people
to the African sugar-producing
island of South Tome
and West Africa, island
off of West Africa
and to Portugal itself,
since the early 16th century,
Portuguese military expeditions
later in that same century
against Ndongo and also Congo
where the immediate
circumstances had generated
thousands of enslaved war
captives including those
that came in 1619.
As I mentioned, Portugal had
established a small colony
Angola in 1575, making
it the first African area
under European occupation
during the early years
of the Atlantic slave trade.
And this trade, of course,
extends across the world,
the transatlantic trade
from 1502 until 1870.
This period of time when about
15 million Africans would have
boarded ships, and about 12
million Africans would have
arrived in the Americas.
Why the disparity of 15
million leaving Africa
and 12 million arriving
in the Americas?
The middle passage, right.
So an estimated 20 to 25%
of those Africans boarding those
ships in Africa did not make it
to the other side, Angela and
her fellow captives that arrived
in Port Comfort with
those who survived.
Now the Portuguese
dynamic is important here
because Angola became
a launching point
for Portuguese governors to
initiate war, specifically
to generate war captives.
Angolan-based Portuguese
merchants held the asiento,
a contract with the Spanish
crown to deliver thousands
of slaves, enslaved people I
should say, to Spanish colonies.
So this combination of
policy, Portuguese policy,
to engage in war and a
contract, a commercial contract,
created a dynamic where
warfare was deliberately used
to generate war captives
and enslaved people.
And now 1619 Africans
were part of this dynamic.
The Portuguese governor in 1617,
Luis Mendes de Vasconcellos
Mendes was bent on conquests
as the only means to get
the numbers that he wanted,
an estimated 9,000
to 12,000 annually.
In his reign from 1617 to 1621
over 50,000 Africans were
exported from Luanda.
Over 150 slave ships left
the Angolan port of Luanda,
including our 1619 Africans.
Now in contrast to
popular perceptions
that African tribal wars were
the cause of slave trading,
it was these military
expeditions of the Portuguese
with mercenary militaristic
Africans known as the Imbangala
that drove these chaotic
lawless conditions.
In this war context then,
slavery became ubiquitous.
Slave economies developed
as the buying and selling
of enslaved people entered
African regional commercial
networks and slaves, not silver
money, became the currency
for all financial transactions
and for political tribute paid
by lesser states to
more powerful states
to whom they claimed
allegiance to.
These enslaved Africans like
Angela, deeply traumatized
by the circumstances
of their enslavement,
their forced separation
from family and friends
and the stripping of
their societal identities.
Imagine, all of who you are,
connected to all the people
that you love, no
longer matters.
That you are reduced,
dehumanized,
to be a unit of labor.
Imagine then that at
the point of capture,
which could be hundreds
of miles in the interior,
you are already starting a type
of middle passage even before
you step foot on a ship.
Because quite often, the point
of capture during this point
of the Atlantic slave
trade could be
in the interior of Africa.
And you could be marched to the
coast over hundreds of miles
and be sold over and over again
with different owners before
you even get to a ship.
And then imagine Angela and
her fellow captives boarding
that ship and being in the
holds of these slave ships.
And perhaps being
raped, women, children
and sometimes men, raped.
Imagine being chained to the
holds where there is nowhere
to go to the bathroom.
Imagine for the first
time being on an ocean.
Many Africans had never seen the
ocean much less been on a ship.
And dealing with the seasickness
that comes with that and having
to wallow in your
excrement and your vomit.
And dealing with a disease
that runs rampant in the holds.
Dysentery was a major killer.
And in the age of wind and
sail, when you had to rely
on the winds and the currents
to make it across the ocean,
that journey could take months.
And you could run out of food.
And already in a weakened state,
if you are perceived to be one
of the diseased or one of
the ones who are too weak
to make it across, you'd
be thrown overboard
where the sharks
that had learned
to follow these ships
would eat you.
Imagine that experience for
Angela and her fellow captives
that might have dealt
with some of this.
We do know that Angela was one
of 350 enslaved people loaded
onto the San Juan Bautista,
a Portuguese slaving ship,
leaving Luanda, bound
for the Spanish colony
in Veracruz, Mexico.
That was supplying the
numbers needed in that asiento.
In Veracruz, they would
have joined a growing slave
population that included
plantation workers
and personal servants.
But, they didn't make it
to Veracruz, as we know.
They made it to Point Comfort.
So what happened?
In route to Veracruz, the
San Juan Bautista stopped
in Jamaica, selling 24 children.
And there were many
children on these voyages.
And they were exchanged
for needed supplies.
Perhaps the San Juan Bautista
was running low on supplies.
Now just a few days
away from Mexico,
the San Juan Bautista
was boarded
by two English privateers,
The White Lion,
The White Lion was carrying
a Dutch license to wage war
on the pirate ships,
and The Treasurer.
And those two ships took cargo
off of the San Juan Bautista
and about 60 enslaved people
with them, including Angela
and our 20 and odd
Negroes, or Africans.
In late August 1619,
the White Lion arrived
in the Virginia settlement
that was encroaching upon
Native American territories.
Trading their 20 and odd
Negroes for victuals.
This is the [inaudible]
record food.
Angela and approximately 28
other captive Africans arrived
on The Treasurer four days
later after The White Lion.
But The Treasurer had sailed
on to a second English colony
of Bermuda, where most were
sold, including Angela.
But in February 1620,
Angela and a handful
of other original captives
from the San Juan Bautista found
themselves once again boarding
The Treasurer where they
landed back in Virginia.
And she and her fellow captives
from West Central Africa
were most, if not all,
of the 32 Africans recorded
in Virginia's May 1620 census.
As I conclude, passing
through Imbangala, Portuguese,
Dutch and English hands,
the experience of Angela
and her fellow captives
foreshadowed major themes
in Africa and the
Atlantic world.
The Portuguese colony of Angola
reflected an early example
of intensifying slave
rating and slavery in Africa
and deepening European
economic interests
that would lead indirectly
to European colonialism,
of virtually all of Africa,
nearly three centuries later.
Luanda, the port from
which Angela and the 20
and odd Africans came
would be the export site
for 1.3 million other captives
over the entire Atlantic
slave trade period.
More than any other
African port.
Angela's story also
provides a glimpse
of the increased Atlantic world
presence of not just the Spanish
and the Portuguese, but
particularly of the Dutch
and the English and
the soon to be French
who are moving beyond
just pirating Portuguese
and Spanish ships for their
riches gained from slavery,
but to establish
their own colonies
in the Western Hemisphere.
And Jamestown was part
of that early effort.
England would be the
largest slave trading nation
in the 18th century.
To these erstwhile pirates
and aspirant colonists,
Angela and other enslaved
people would be critical
in generating untold
wealth for new societies
that were race-based, that
developed racial caste systems,
echoes of which we
still live with today.
Despite common perceptions
that enslaved Africans
came almost exclusively
from West Africa, and many did,
Angela's story illuminates
the fact that most
of the 500,000 African women,
men and children that arrived
in the Americas by 1619 came
from West Central Africa.
It was these West Central
Africans like Angela
that were the chartered
generations,
those first generations
of Africans
and the largest force
migration in world history
that laid the foundation
for the African diaspora
and the Americas.
Thank you for listening.
[ Applause ]
>> Cassandra Newby-Alexander:
Good afternoon.
My colleague has beautifully
laid out the foundation.
And I'm going to talk about
the rest of the story.
I'm going to take
you, not from the West
or Central African coastlines,
but rather to Virginia,
to the first place
where America began.
That beginning in 1619
with the arrival of the 20
and odd Negroes aboard the
English ship White Lion,
people of African descent
became a permanent cultural
and political fixture
in America.
For the first century, the vast
majority of the Africans coming
to Virginia were from
Central and West Africa.
Subjected to a kind of
forced acculturation
that accompanied
their enslavement,
Africans adapted over time.
This, however, did not imply
that they divested themselves
of their African culture.
Instead, they infused America's
evolving customs with art,
music, culinary practices,
trading systems, agricultural
and architectural
techniques and language,
creating a creole society
that became the foundation
of an emerging American culture.
And though initially
small in number,
these first-generation Africans
helped define even the concepts
of freedom and liberty
because of their ongoing demand
for inclusion and civil rights.
Through this effort, they helped
establish an international
definition of freedom.
Indeed, as the past 400
years will attest, Africans
and their descendants
embarked on a quest
to restore their humanity
and to be recognized
as true American citizens.
After Africans began arriving
in the Virginia colony,
many of the English officials
became these first owners
of these people.
Their plantations, as
you can see on this map
that is a map created by Smith
in the early part
of the 17th century.
And I want you to pay attention
to this because this kind
of takes our vantage point,
our viewpoint, and changes it.
It shifts it.
Our viewpoint is like this.
But the map takes it
and moves it that way.
Because when you
see the Chesapeake,
the Chesapeake is
usually, in our maps,
depicted almost north and south.
But this one actually
moves it almost
to an east-west direction.
And that is because that
was the vantage point
of the first people.
It shows their trade
and their connections.
And that's why the first
Africans, when they arrived,
the English when they arrived,
the settled on the same lands
and oriented themselves
in the same way as many
of the Native peoples
who established the towns
and cities in Virginia.
So these plantations that the
English gravitated towards
and created for themselves
were located on one of the 18
to 19 prime sites, so
along the James River.
Starting between
April of 1619 and 120,
the early Africans were
concentrated in these areas,
James City, Elizabeth City
and Suri [phonetic] Counties.
In these early years,
the Africans who appeared
in the records typically were
listed along with their owners
and often with only a first
name, belying their status
in the colony, even during these
critical foundational years.
According to the Virginia
muster records of 1624, 1625,
21 Africans lived in
the colonized area
of Abraham Percy's plantation,
now known as Flowerdew
Plantation or Flowerdew Hundred.
Only four out of the 11 people
mentioned were mentioned
by name.
So the rest of the people
didn't even have an identity
as a human being.
Well, those four people
included Anthony, Williams,
John and another Anthony.
If you notice, they lacked
a last name, a surname,
a name that would
give them civil rights
because it would recognize
them as human beings.
In the township of Jamestown,
there were three Africans
who were listed with
only one listed by name,
and that name was misspelled.
The woman's name was Angela, and
yet, they listed her as Angelo.
Angela was the first
African woman documented.
She was forcibly brought
into the Virginia colony,
as you heard earlier, on
this ship, The Treasurer.
She was listed as the property
of Captain William Pierce.
She was referred to as quote,
that Negro woman
who raised pigs.
Angela was probably working
with Pierce's wife, Joan,
to maintain a three
two four-acre garden.
Another Angolan brought into
the colony was named Edward.
Identified as living
on a plantation called
Necoland [phonetic].
The owner was Richard Kingsmill.
Four other Angolans lived on
the Bennett Plantation, Peter,
Anthony, Francis and Margaret.
While two others lived
at Elizabeth City,
which is now Hampton, with
Captain William Tucker.
And their names,
Anthony and Isabella.
And reportedly, Anthony
and Isabella
who were married has a child
in 1624 that they named
after Captain William
Tucker, who interestingly,
became the child's godfather,
thereby protecting
that child's status.
Francis Payne was enslaved by
William Eltonhead [phonetic],
but by 1655, he was
listed as a free man
with a wife and children.
And he actually owned
land on Cherrystone Creek,
located on the eastern shore.
Emmanuel Drigues
[phonetic] or Rodrigues,
was listed as the property of
Captain Francis Pott in 1645.
And while it is unclear
when he became free,
he was part of a
minority of Africans
who gained their freedom,
securing 145 acres of land
on the eastern shore on King's
Creek in North Hampton County.
Similarly, William
Harmon, who was transported
to the Virginia colony
and enslaved in 1662
to William Kendall in North
Hampton County, again,
on the eastern shore, was
freed six years later in 1668,
and he was listed in the
records along with is wife,
who interestingly, was listed
with both a first and last name,
Jane Gossell [phonetic].
And he was listed as raising
cattle on the eastern shore.
So while there were some whose
status changed from enslaved
to free, the vast majority of
these early Africans were locked
in a system of perpetual
servitude
within the American
colonies' first slaving zone.
Even so, Africans
successfully adapted their labor
and [inaudible] and traditions
to this new environment
with responsibilities
that included agricultural
production, cooking,
construction and
household management.
It was during these early
years that African food
and culinary practices
were incorporated
into the Virginia colony.
For example, the Virginia house
was an adapted architectural
model that English
colonists began constructing,
similar to the shotgun houses
you see commonly in the South.
Unlike the English houses that
were designed to retain heat
and limit airflow
throughout the house,
the Virginia houses
were constructed
to do just the opposite
because of the warm temperatures
and the humid environment.
In early Virginia, northern
Native American foods
such as corn, squash, pumpkin
and beans, were integrated
into the English diet.
These foods intersected
with the culinary traditions
that the English introduced
into America that included pigs
and cattle, chicken and sheep,
wheat, flour, onions, carrots
and a variety of
greens and beans.
They also introduced sweet
potatoes and white potatoes
to the colonies through
this Atlantic trade.
When the Africans were brought
into the American colonies,
many of their native plants
accompanied them aboard these
ships, including black-eyed
peas, okra, yams, peanuts,
watermelons, sesame
seeds, cassava,
kola nuts, and lima beans.
And because Africans were
brought into the colonies
and lived and worked in
the households of some
of the most prominent planters,
the same planters, by the way,
responsible for transporting
supplies into the colony
and establishing the cultural
tone, they were tasked
with these cooking duties.
Historian Donna Gabaccia
argued, and I quote,
"It was African slaves'
central position as producers
and processors of
food that allowed them
to leave their own
special mark."
It was in the Central
and West African areas,
or I should say it was the
Central and West Africans
who laid the foundations
for the cuisine
that we know today
as southern cooking.
Which infused dishes with hot
pepper and spices, millet,
peanuts and sweet potatoes.
For example, as they
mixed fried okra with rice
and black-eyed peas using
slow cooking techniques
to produce dishes like
gumbo and peanut soup,
their African culinary practices
altered the way the English
and Native Americans
consumed food.
Culinary Historian
Jessica Harris observed
that food traditions
provide a historical roadmap
for American society.
Because the foods we eat
hold symbols and meaning
that connects us with our ethnic
origins and shared creole past.
America's colonial cookbooks
reflected the creolization
of foods and food ways
while simultaneously erasing
or making invisible the
contributions of the people
who created those food ways
and customs to begin with.
Scholar Alisha Cromwell noted
that the challenge, therefore,
is "studying the silences"
of how Africans contributed
to the evolution of
American culture.
Religious expression of
these 17th century Africans,
as Rebecca Goetz's 2012
groundbreaking work,
The Baptism of Early
Virginia noted, how Africans
in Virginia used
religion as the vehicle
by which they individually
and collectively
expressed their voice.
During the colonial period,
many sought to retain elements
of their African customs and
manners to the frustration
of whites who regarded
their refusal to assimilate
as indicators of their
heathenism and inferiority.
Yet, these 17th century Africans
came armed with the knowledge
of ecclesiastical and
theological rules called
from their knowledge
of Catholicism
because of their contact
with the Portuguese.
For a short period,
Africans were even able
to use baptism practices and
the legal protections that came
from godparents as pathways
to freedom and a way
to build community networks.
Thus, the American colonial
period was replete with examples
of how Africans infused their
various cultural practices
into the overall culture
that was evolving during these
early years, impacting everyone,
not just those within
their community,
but the entire community of
Virginia and later of America.
Religion, music, food ways,
customs, oral traditions,
language and art became uniquely
American because of the African.
Patent jubah [phonetic] which
was the beating of the hands
on the thighs and the stomping
of the heels of the feet
to produce percussion music.
Fiddle and banjo music became
the traditional entertainment
forms among Africans
and African-Americans.
And because these individuals
were the primary musicians,
especially in Virginia, they
impacted the way that everyone
in the colony and later
in the nation saw music,
heard music, felt music.
These kinds of musical
practices were the most popular
and most highly in demand.
The intersection of
countless African ethnicities
through the transatlantic
slave trade journey
and in the American crucible
created a new form of culture
that combined these
traditions with those
of the English and
Native peoples.
And while these new
practices and traditions
that were influenced
so effectively
by primarily these enslaved
Africans that culture
as African-American novelist
Ralph Ellison noted was,
"more than the sum of
this brutalization."
Instead, acknowledging
the impact of Africans
in the formation of American's
culture, is an affirmation
of life and the attitudes
of those who became part
of the American experience.
And for those Africans
in American, the infusion
of their cultures into the
American landscape while
assimilating and
acculturating meant
that they were an important
part of transforming, mutating
and even creating a
unique hybrid culture
that we call American.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Lynette Lewis Allston:
First, thank you to Dr. Braxton
and to the Library of
Congress for allowing me
to give you all the Native
perspective on early Virginia.
From the arrival of the English
in 1607 until the 1619 arrival
of Africans and European women,
the world of the Native people
of Virginia was drastically
altered.
The clash of cultures brought
disruption of lifestyle,
loss of oral tradition
and language,
assault of manifest
destiny on spiritual
and religious practices,
resulting in prejudice
and death.
The challenge in explaining
how the Native population felt
about the arrival
of new people is
to make my 21st century
unselfish view of living
in the early 17th century
because Native people
transferred information
from generation to generation
through oral tradition.
Much of that information
has been lost.
The sources of written
accounts from early times
in Virginia are found
in personal writings
such as diaries and in the
collection of statutes and laws
that were created by those
who arrived at Jamestown.
Through time, much has been
written about the early times
in Virginia by people who
have offered their analysis
and perspective,
their speculation
and their imagination to address
their views of the events.
In most cases, the people who
wrote about life in Jamestown
in the 17th century were not
altruistic in their accounts.
They were people who had
more to gain than to give.
Was the first reaction
by the Native tribes
that these newcomers
are here to harm?
Did their curiosity
about the first Europeans
and then Africans overcome fear?
Long before 1619, indigenous
communities were accustomed
to the arrival of
persons from far away.
Usually, these travelers
were indigenous people
from other locales coming
for trade, and they were
of similar skin color.
They spoke languages that
at least some words could
be understood.
They came, they socialized,
they traded, and they left
to come again another time.
These new visitors who came
by ships looked different,
spoke an unknown
language and brought
with them curiously
different goods.
Were they like the others
here to trade and depart?
Or did they have a
different motive?
In short order, it became
obvious that this group
of strangers who brought
no women with them
in the first phase
were different
from previous visitors.
Native curiosity was tempered
by an awareness of danger
and soon turned to unease.
Unease turned to fear, and
fear turned to loathing.
By 1619, the reality of
conflict was a part of living
with the presence of people
who exhibited cultural biases
and invasive socioeconomic
goals.
Within a short time of
arriving in Jamestown,
the colonists were engaged
in the cycle of attacks
and reprisals by the paladin
tribes who saw the reality
that the arrival of these
new people was an invasion.
Just 12 years after the arrival
of the strangers in 1607,
the tribes saw the coming
of more unfamiliar arrivals,
Africans, and finally
a few European women.
The attack on the Native
population was not only
physically with weapons
and disease,
there was also a cultural
attack with religion, education,
gender roles, forced
apprenticeships
on Native children, forced
indenture, slavery and loss
of identity through
paper genocide.
With the establishment of the
colonial government in 1619
and the meeting of the House
of Burgesses, the direction
for defining race and
class and separation began.
Statutes at large, laws of
Virginia began the process
of creating barriers and
restrictions on those
who were viewed by Angelo
men as being subordinate.
This new societal strata
enhanced the evolution
of interaction between
Native people, Africans,
women and the indentured
population.
Some of that interaction
was natural
and voluntary, and
some was coerced.
The laws of Virginia show that
English mindset towards Natives
with citations, even
in the index of laws
that created references that
say savages, "see Indians."
The threat of quasi
slavery was ever present.
In 1655, there's
a law that states
if Indian parents bring their
children in as hostages,
then choose the persons to
care for their children.
They will not be used as slaves.
But we will do our best to bring
them into Christianity, civility
and the knowledge
of necessary trades.
Now this may sound like a
benevolent idea, but in reality,
it is a method of acculturation.
Also, in 1655, it was deemed "a
great scandal to Christianity,
rendering religion
contemptable to buy an Indian.
Yet, selling an Indian, who
had committed an infraction,
was acceptable.
As stated in a 1660 decision
that resulted from an accusation
of damages done on English
property and states if they,
the Indians, do not comply then
so many as the court think fit,
shall be apprehended and sold
into a foreign country
to satisfy the award.
Through a series of
violent confrontations,
subsequent documents that the
colonial government labeled
as treaties, traditional Native
cultural patterns of trade,
travel and even selection of
leadership, was transformed.
Methods were instituted
to control traditional
indigenous leadership structure.
We read historical documents
which label various Natives
as chiefs, queens, kings,
headmen, without realizing
that title terms were
generated by the colonists.
As an example, in 1663,
the colonial statute stated the
Indians shall not have the power
within themselves to elect
or constitute their
own chief commander.
But the present honorable
governor
and his successors shall
authorize such person.
By the time of Nathanial Bacon's
oddly-named rebellion in 1676,
those who fought could keep
a captured Native as a reward
for assisting and
attacking the Occaneechi.
Field historians
have acknowledged
that Nathanial Bacon's primary
objective was to disrupt one
of the largest pre-Anglo
trading centers near present-day
Clarksville, Virginia.
By decimating the Occaneechi,
Bacon was positioning himself
and other Anglos to control
a major historical indigenous
trade route.
Accurate history is filled
with unpleasant realities.
And I acknowledge this because
a segment of my own tribe,
the Nottoway, assisted Bacon
in the slaughter
of the Occaneechis.
If we seek historical
reconciliation, we must be open
to addressing immoral
ambiguity and unpleasantries.
There was an ongoing and
everchanging list of early laws
on anti-miscegenation, birth
of mixed-race children,
trade with Natives,
Natives traveling
through land appropriate
by colonists and more.
The most obvious and sensitive
issue is disparate consideration
of racial intermarriage.
The way we looked,
the visual appearance
of the Native population, had
much to do with the attraction
for interaction between
Natives and Africans.
An example of appearances
provided
in the 1700s diary
of William Bird.
Bird visited the Nottoway
great town during his travels
to survey the border between
Virginia and North Carolina.
Bird described the Nottoway
as people of mahogany skins
and the copper colored
ones of Nottoway town.
He described the Nottoway this
way long before an extensive
intermarriage with Nottoway with
either Europeans or Africans.
Over time, the Nottoway
did intermarry
with Europeans and Africans.
We can assume that there
was an inclination of people
of darker skin tones who
were viewed and had to act,
and were acted upon
as subordinate
to establish common bonds
for safety and survival.
To that end, the
Nottoway tribe who lived
in the 1700s were
living on 40,000 acres
of reservation land,
provided safe haven
for segments of displaced
tribes.
Escaped slaves and
runaway indentures,
also found save haven
on that reservation.
At the time that Bird was
surveying the Virginia North
Carolina dividing line, the
Weyanoke Tribe had been removed
from its territory
from the James River.
In a deposition of Henry
Briggs in 1711, Briggs states
that the Weyanoke live
on Wyocake [phonetic]
on the Nottoway River and have
paid the Nottoway much peak
to live there.
At the same time,
segments of other tribes,
including Meherrin,
Nansemond and Tuscarora came
to live with the Nottoway.
The Nottoway 40,000-acre
reservation was a buffer
against Anglo conflicts
with the Tuscarora
who were stridently resistant
to colonial usurpation
of their land.
The Nottoway reservation was
in present day South Hampton
and Sussex County in Virginia.
With the loss of territory,
some Virginia natives were able
to survive by living
on reservation,
and others became servants
and laborers on land
that was once their own.
In the 19th century, the
Nottoway took allotments
of reservation land and
became individual landowners.
Yet, as individual landowners,
we were subject to taxes.
And if we did not pay those
taxes, we were subject
to involuntary indenture.
1619 was the pinnacle
marker for racial
and gender discrimination
laws that compounded
and impacted Native identity
into the 20th century.
Native people traditionally had
a balanced view of gender roles
and the importance of women.
Native women were involved
as decision makers
in tribal structure.
As time passed, Native
identity was transitioned
to other designations
based on skin color.
In Virginia, paper genocide
systematically categorized
Natives as people of color
and erased Native identity
on census records
and legal documents.
The Racial Integrity Act of
1924 in its implementation
by Walter Plecker as head of
the Bureau of Vital Statistics
for Virginia mandated that
there were only two races
in Virginia, white and colored.
The Racial Integrity
Act remained until 1967,
when the US Supreme
Court in Loving
versus Virginia found the law
prohibiting interracial marriage
to be unconstitutional.
A subsequent change in
Virginia law restored identity
and allowed birth certificates
of Virginia tribal
members to be corrected.
In today's world, I remind
citizens of my tribe,
including one that's sitting
on the front row over here,
that the Nottoway
Indian Tribe of Virginia,
that our first family
were Native people.
And that anyone else who
came along simply joined us,
and that made us
who we are today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Joanne M. Braxton:
Thank you Trent, Cassandra
and Lynette, and I am last.
Today I'm going to speak
about just a very small part
of my work here at
the Kluge Center.
And my larger project on
African-American spirituality
and health is on view under
the title At the Crossroads
of Spirituality and Health
on the Kluge Center website.
So, today's talk is red-black,
spirit medicine in
the Chesapeake.
Origins of the Weyanoke,
1619 to the present.
And this slide show is just
going to run while I talk.
Because there's so
much information,
you can't possibly do justice
to it in a few minutes.
The slides will help.
Many of these are from
professional photographers
of Faith Charity Nelson
and also Valena Dismukes.
Also Allan Alston and
Rebecca Parker, who are here,
contributed some of the slides.
And you'll see one image
by Rose Paliton [phonetic],
the artist who is
sitting in the front row.
And if you can't tell who that
is, just look to the front row
and there is someone who looks
most decidedly like an artist.
So welcome, dear friend, Rose.
Red Black Spirit Medicine.
This story is personal and at
the same time representative
of the spiritual journey of
many persons of mixed triracial
or red-black heritage.
Perhaps for me, it
begins in my childhood
in Prince George's
County, Maryland.
On the banks of a stream
that fed the Anacostia River.
Long before I ever thought
about being a scholar
of African-American
literature and culture.
When I was a child, we lived
in a house in the woods just
on the banks of Indian Creek.
The boundary between our black
and mixed-race community
and another world.
A world that was largely white.
But throughout this region
in the time before there was a
beltway, there were communities
like ours with tightly
interwoven kinship relations.
My father taught me how
to cup my hands to drink
from a metal bucket
or clear spring.
How to set traps for rabbits
and how to find the North Star.
The older men moved like shadows
in and out of the forest,
emerging with squirrel, rabbits
and occasionally other game.
I roamed the woods and wetlands,
watchful for water moccasins
and dangerous sinkholes.
We farmed the land
growing corn, beans,
squash and occasionally melon.
We caught and cooked the
eels from Indian Creek,
frying them up in hot grease to
eat with hominy and succotash.
In the spring, my father's
mother would prepare a physic
of pokeweed, a poisonous
plant that I learned
to pick before its
purple berries formed.
And Dad would head down
into Southern Maryland
with my mother's Gus
and butler cousins
for the spring herring run.
Dad and Cousin Amos Gus
caught lots of herring,
and they salted them down
and preserved in a barrel.
Only later did I learn that the
food practices of my family,
such as the salting of
herring and the growing
of the three sisters
were tangible signs
of the cultural interaction
of red and black people.
My mother's mother
was a red-brown woman
who could heal ailments
with plants from the forest.
This she learned from
her grandmother, Nana,
who as my grandmother told
me, had long black hair,
hair long enough to sit on.
From my paternal grandmother,
I learned about my great-great
grandfather Peyton Harrison,
Black and Indian who
came up from Virginia.
He told my grandmother
that his people were some
of the Jamestown Africans.
Sometimes, as I roam
through the woods or dug clay
from the stream bank, I did
wonder where the Indians
for whom Indian Creek
was named had gone.
But then my mind would
return to the present
and the pending threat of
integration, which had not
yet occurred but
was looming over us.
In those days, colored children
from Southern Prince George's
County came all the way
up into Lakeland to attend
our Colored Lakeland School.
No one was black back then.
We were all Colored with a
capital C. Call somebody Black,
you're going to start a fight.
Those proctored [phonetic]
children,
they didn't associate
with us much.
We thought they were strange
with their straight hair
and their standoff ways.
Only recently did
I learn that many
of the proctors now
self-identify
as Piscataway Indians.
And only when urban renewal
conspired to take what I thought
of our land there on
Indian Creek did I begin
to appreciate the convergence
of things I had seen
and the stories I had heard.
It was these stories of my
ancestors in the Chesapeake
that fueled my desire to
learn more about the Weyanoke,
both as a scholar and as
a symbolic descendant.
In time, I learned that Weyanoke
is at once a people, a place
or places and incorporated
association and ritual ground
where the collective historical
trauma of colonialism.
The enslavement of black and
Native people and the trauma
of separation and
exclusion gets repaired
through collective
healing prayers, music,
ritual and the intentional
coming together
of persons prepared to
celebrate red-black connections.
The name Weyanoke itself means
sassafras, a medicinal tree used
for healing purposes
by indigenous people
transported Africans
and European colonists alike.
And today, the Weyanoke
Association is first
and foremost a site of healing.
The Chesapeake or Great
Shellfish Bay was the site
of the Weyanoke Plantation
in Virginia,
where the first Africans in
the English Americas lived
in community dating from 1619.
Transported to the Chesapeake
region through Point Comfort,
near present-day Hampton
and from thence to Jamestown
and from there on to the
Weyanoke Plantation named
for the indigenous
people who lived nearby,
the 1619 Angolan Africans began
their lives in close proximity
to an Algonquian-speaking
people whose ancestors had been
in the region for at least
1,600 years before the English
colonizers arrived.
The Africans learned to hunt
and fish with the Weyanoke,
lighting fires in
their canoes at night
to warm their hands
and to attract fish.
There were many similarities
between the indigenous
read people
and the transported Africans.
Each was subjected to
"colonialism, social disorder
and upheaval for
hundreds of years
and to being called savages.
The object of this immense and
intense culture interaction
and it's resultant degradation
is the Weyanoke Association
website points out, was
to take the red man's land
and use the black man's
labor to work that land."
On the positive side,
the indigenous Native
American people
and Africans alike had oral
traditions that allowed
for the preservation of
ancestry and records.
And the conveying of
identity and knowledge
through the cultivation
of deep listening skill
and respect for the elders.
These were skills that
could spell the difference
between physical
survival and annihilation.
As folkways had the power to
give direction and guidance
from ancestral knowledge,
even when no ancestor
was physically present.
And in many ways, the
Africans' spirituality
and cosmology may have
been compatible with that
of their original
indigenous hosts,
along with their musical
traditions and practices
of midwifery or biology
and other forms
of traditional healing.
Both peoples had
priests, conjurers,
diviners and midwives.
Each had a closeness
and an interdependent
relationship to the land.
By following the language
of the way that black
and red people are described
in colonial Virginia laws,
it is possible to see how
ideas of race changed over time
and were used as tools
to divide two people
who had much in common.
As documented by Arica Coleman
in her award-winning book,
That the Blood Stay
Pure, African-Americans,
Native-Americans and the
predicament of identity
in Virginia, relations between
indigenous persons and persons
of African dissent in Virginia
have often been troubled
with Virginia's Racial Purity
Act disrupting relationships
among individuals,
families, churches and tribes.
Today, the Weyanoke Association
founded by Hugh and Anita Herald
in 1999 on the 380th anniversary
of the landing of Africans
in Virginia has become a site
of memory and spiritual healing
for those simultaneously
remembering, navigating
and reconciling with this
rich and complicated past.
When I speak of red-black
spirit medicine, I am speaking
of medicine that originates with
red or black people that is good
for black-red people, or anyone
else who needs the physical,
emotional or psychological care
that red-black spirit
medicine can provide.
Think of it as complementary
care
for the body, mind and spirit.
Think of it as redress, to
use Saidiya Hartman's term,
or soul repair for the
intersecting layers of violence
and historical trauma and spirit
murder, to borrow from the work
of Nell Painter and later
Kelly Brown Douglas.
The work of Jack Saul has shown
that collective trauma
is often best addressed
in community with others.
That is what the Weyanoke
Association achieves
in their annual coming
together gatherings and powwows.
The healing may attract
physical health, excuse me,
may impact physical
health or just the spirit.
I felt that healing personally
when Hugh Harrell poured a
fresh pot of sassafras tea,
and we sat down in a home rich
with art and ritual objects
from both African and
indigenous culture.
And Anita Harrell read
a poem called It isn't
Identity Politics.
Here's the poem.
I am Anita Harrell.
I am Moon Dancer.
I am the daughter of Allene
[phonetic] Davis Alan.
I am the daughter of
Annie Miles Davis Heron.
I am the great-granddaughter
of N.E. [phonetic] Smith Miles.
I am the great-great
granddaughter of Lavenia Smith.
Because of them, I am Shoshone.
Because of them, I am loved.
Because of them, I am strong.
Because of them, I
am who I say I am.
I am Moon Dancer.
I am Anita Harrel.
Who are you?
And then she said, if you
use a blood quantum approach,
you are essentially
committing suicide, end quote.
Hugh, a descendant
of many generations
of Charles City County
red-blacks agrees.
He says, we've been doing
what we've been doing
because we had to.
There's no emphasis
in local schools
on teaching children
their history.
Anita added, I know
Erica started her work,
this is Dr. Arica Coleman, I
know Erica started her work
after coming to one
of our gatherings.
There's an alignment
with the ancestors.
Things happening beyond
our control, end quote.
Each year, on the second
Saturday in August,
to coincide with the
anniversary of their arrival
of the first Africans
in Virginia,
the Weyanoke Association
sponsors the Coming Together
Festival, the Lincoln legacy of
Native and African-Americans.
To embark on a journey
to a Weyanoke Coming
Together Festival,
one must leave physically
the spaces and places
of colonization and go into the
wilderness, up into the woods
in Charles City County
or Surry County
into historically
red and black spaces.
One leaves Richmond, the
capital of the Confederacy
or colonial Williamsburg,
literally
and historically the
colonial capital.
From Williamsburg,
one drives west
on Route 5 past Weyanoke
Plantation
where Yardley hid most of
the 19 Angolan Africans
who were imported illegally
into Jamestown in 1619.
And then on past
Berkley Plantation
where Benjamin Harrison
traded extensively
with indigenous people.
And some Weyanoke
people lived in houses
on that Harrison property.
There, on the Weyanoke
Peninsula, just five miles
from the place where the
indentured Africans formed their
first community.
In fact, many of the Coming
Together gatherings have been
held as the Harrison
National Fish Hatcheries,
part of the original
Harrison Estate,
which keeps the historical
continuities tight.
To go to Coming Together, one
travels through greenspaces
and through symbolic geography
and psychic landscapes
to become removed,
sheltered and inoculated.
To claim and be reclaimed.
Once arrived, the healing can
begin in ways large and small
in spaces where the mind
can begin to be decolonized,
and everyone is invited
to break bread
and enjoy the transcendent
rhythms of sacred drums,
healing songs and chants,
processions honoring the
ancestors and dancing.
The protocol of Coming
Together includes both African
and Native elements.
Everyone is welcome.
But one must be intentional
about the choice
to make the journey to go there.
Walking in a Weyanoke procession
and hearing the transcendent
rhythms
of two cultures can
be a powerful source
of reconnection and renewal.
Especially for one who
has read in black roots.
There is medicine in
the knowledge shared,
in the smudging, in the
libations, in the prayers,
in the food, in the belonging.
For me, the Who's Afraid
of Black Indians poems,
talk about a slip.
For me, the Who's Afraid
of Black Indians poems
of Weyanoke Association member
Shonda Buchanan are restorative.
Not unlike the narrative
medicine I've taught
at William & Mary and Eastern
Virginia Medical School,
there is more medicine
in the photographs
of Faith Charity Nelson
and Valena Dismukes
and in the paintings
of Rose Paliton
and the pottery of
Lynnette Allston.
Beyond this, Anita Harrell
has taken her healing rituals
into her work as a family
system's constellations therapy
facilitator, and similar
therapies were recently employed
in a Braxton Institute advanced
training seminar for 100 helpers
and healers seeking
training in moral injury
and collective healing
in September 2017.
African-American
and Native-American healers have
access to knowledge, culture
and power when we stand in our
own medicine and our own truth.
I conclude with a prayer
from the Weyanoke
Association website.
We give thanks to the
Creator for each new day.
ancestors who watch over us.
We give thanks to our Mother
Earth who sustains us.
We give thanks to our brothers
and sisters, the plants
and animals, who give our lives
so that ours may continue.
We give thanks to the
people who've work,
care and love nourish us.
We give thanks that [inaudible]
and Turtle Island meet in us.
We give thanks to the Creator
for all of these gifts.
May they be transformed into
positive thoughts, careful
and kind words, appropriate
and effective deeds.
Aho [phonetic], [Foreign
Language] Amen.
>> Aho.
>> Joanne M. Braxton: Aho.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I'm going to shift now to
our panel discussion mode.
There's no graceful way
to pick up index cards.
Before we get started, I would
like to acknowledge the presence
of Nancy Rodriguez and
Uri [phonetic] Mulligan
from Commemoration 2918,
American Evolution.
Would you please stand up?
[ Applause ]
Thank you for your
support of this program.
Dr. Newby-Alexander,
we began working
on our collaborative 2019
commemoration efforts
in preparation for the 400th
anniversary of 1619 way back
in 2012 when we collectively
convened the first 1619
and Making of America conference
at Norfolk State University.
Since that time, we have
constituted ourselves
as a learning community,
a kind of think tank
for revisiting the discussion
of 1619 and its impact
and significance in
American history.
So our team has been
working on this for years.
Why?
>> Cassandra Newby-Alexander:
You know,
it is a difficult story.
What we have to do is
deconstruct the way
in which we see our
nation's history.
The center of the
story has focused
on the European descendants.
And everyone else has been
left out or completely ignored.
And so we brought together
not only scholars but people
in the community to
tell a different story.
To tell a story that's
really who we are.
And we started with asking the
question, who are we really?
And all you have to do
is peel back the layers
of your own family's
history and legacy to know
that the story you tell your
children is not the real story.
You tell the good.
You tell the part of that
story that makes you proud,
that makes you feel
like you have ownership.
But our story is
much more complex.
And so in retelling a story,
in pulling all the
different layers out,
the need to be removed,
and putting into that
narrative what really needs
to be there, it takes a while.
And as you can see even
in today's politics,
people are afraid of that story.
But that's the story
that makes us strong.
That's the story
that makes us unique.
That should be the story
that makes us proud.
>> Joanne M. Braxton: Thank you.
In connection with the original
2012 1619 and the Making
of America conference
at Norfolk State,
I interviewed Dr. Maya Angelou,
and I'd like to bring her
into the room with us right now.
I asked why should 1619 be on
our minds as we face forward
into the 400th anniversary
of the arrival of Africans
and women in the English
colony of Virginia?
What are the enduring
questions raised
by this pivotal moment in time?
And now, I'm quoting Dr.
Maya Angelou who said,
"We have an old saying that has
become a clich and that is,
you can't know where
you're going unless you know
where you've been.
It is imperative," she said,
"that all Americans
recognize the imprint
of the first Africans
brought here
and the first white women
brought here in bondage.
I'm trying to say
that the word slavery
and the term enslavement has
lost so much of its weight,
until the people mouth the words
without realizing what they're
saying, what they're calling up.
When you read the history of
the enslavement, the hundreds
of years of enslavement,
it's too dreadful
to have even been included
in Alex Haley's phenomena
the book Roots
and the television phenomena
Roots in which I," Maya Angelou
"played Kunta Kinte's
grandmother.
Too bizarre.
Too horrible," she says.
"And yet, we have to face
it or we will never get rid
of this blight of racism and
guilt and hate which assembles
in our race in the
21st century."
Panelists, do you
agree with Dr. Angelou?
Why or why not?
What do you feel are the
enduring questions raised
by 1619 for those of
us still here in 2018?
Is 2019 another pivotal moment?
How can having access to the
past, and in particular, 1619,
help us understand the present?
>> Who first?
>> Joanne M. Braxton:
Dr. Vinson.
>> Robert Trent Vinson:
I'll take a stab at that.
Let's see.
So, 2019 is the 400th
anniversary of 1619,
which we're talking about.
And so it gives a chance to talk
about Jamestown and to put it
into context in terms
of the world.
Because on some level,
Jamestown and the context
of the Atlantic slave
trade was peripheral.
I already mentioned 500,000
Africans had already come
across the water.
Only 6% of Africans coming
across the water actually came
to what became the
United States.
The vast majority, over
90%, went to South America,
Central America and
the Caribbean.
Yet, what developed starting
from Jamestown was ultimately
by 1860, the largest slave
society in world history,
four million enslaved
people, right.
And we have to deal with
that dynamic of how it was
that a system of slavery that
has been a global phenomena,
it's in all the ancient
societies,
became so heavily race-based.
And the system of slavery which
has a classic component, right,
appropriating labor to generate
profit for someone else,
included a racial component
now to create this kind
of racial caste system that
in many ways survived slavery
in a legal sense.
And so Jamestown gives
us a chance to reflect
and shift the narrative, because
if we look at 1619 and we go
to 1865, that's 246 years of
slavery, which is more years
than of freedom in this country.
And then if you look at
those years of freedom,
the great majority of that time,
over 100 years, is Jim Crow.
So when we talk about
Jamestown being the beginning
of democracy, that's
from the perspective
of propertied white men.
Democracy is a rather new
thing in America I would argue.
I would argue that we might
have to start thinking
about democracy perhaps with
the Voting Rights Act of 1965.
And even then, it's a fragile
thing as we've come to know.
So we have the largest
prison population
in world history as well.
And we know those who
are branded as felons,
even after they've served
their time and paid their debt
to society, still very difficult
to get their voting rights back
and other rights as well.
So 2019 gives us a moment
to reflect on where we are
in America and where
America is in the world.
That's the best I can do
with such a deep question.
>> That's the best you can do?
[ Applause ]
>> Lynnette Lewis Allston: Well,
I want to chime in on that,
because in Native America,
we deal with what we
call historical trauma.
And it's the mindset, the things
that we have carried with us
through the generations
that control how we interact
with people, what we say,
what we are afraid to say.
Because we feel we, we're
the lowest of the low.
That was what 1619,
1607 began to do
to our culture was make
us afraid of who we are.
So that historical trauma
is still something we're
dealing with.
We are just beginning to talk
about our history,
our perspective.
And it is a revelation.
It is an opportunity to release,
and we look forward to the 2019
to let us have a voice
at the table to talk more
about our perspective.
[ Applause ]
>> Cassandra Newby-Alexander:
So I will chime in as well.
One of the things that I,
I'm going to compare this to,
if you visit a plantation
anywhere in the South
in America, you hear the
story of a handful of people
who own the plantation,
their lives, their traumas,
what they ate, what they
wore, whether they died,
whether they had diseases.
But you don't hear anything
about people who made sure
that that plantation thrived,
survived, produced the goods.
You don't hear about the trauma
that those individuals endured.
You don't hear about
the work that went
into creating this
plantation that thrived.
You don't read about how
these were the individuals
who actually built, or
constructed the buildings,
planted the fields, maintained
the economic integrity
of that particular plantation.
For you, the visitor,
they are invisible.
They are the side story that you
don't even really get to hear.
And so going back
400 years is critical
to the survival of our country.
Because we have created such a
false narrative of who we are.
We've created, sustained
and held
on with both hands
this lie about America.
This lie about how the
English arrived and bam,
there was this gorgeous
creative, incredible nation
that sprang out of nothing.
With no one else's help
but the handful of English
who first arrived and
their descendants.
That's the narrative
that you hear.
But that is a lie.
And so it is critical that we
go back and not only deconstruct
that lie but tell you why the
truth is far more important
and far more of a guide to
who we can be for the future.
And so, you know, in history,
sometimes it takes distance
from a certain event
for us to really begin
to want to face our pain.
And today, in today's
society, you have a number
of psychologists
and sociologists
who are now studying this
posttraumatic stress disorder
that many people of African
and Native descent
have been experiencing
for the past 400 plus
years in this society.
Many people talk about, well,
why aren't African-Americans
thriving
like all these other immigrants
coming to this country?
Well, none of the other
immigrants have to go
through an ongoing process that
African-Americans went through.
So it comforts us
to blame the victim
for their own victimization
and to ignore the
realities of our society.
We talk about the
poverty and the alcoholism
of the Native peoples, but we
don't talk about how we put many
of them on land that not even
a tumbleweed survives on.
And so we, this is the time.
This is the time when America
can look back and begin
to reconcile itself
with its own truth.
[ Applause ]
>> Joanne M. Braxton: A couple
more questions before we open it
up to everyone.
Chief Allston, you used a
term that may be unfamiliar
to many folk, and that
term is paper genocide.
Would you please explain
what paper genocide means?
>> Lynette Lewis Allston: Well,
over time, identity is lost.
Within our tribe, we find people
on census records and early
on listed IND, Indian.
But over time, that IND
changed to mulatto, MU.
Or in some instances,
it was changed to white.
And in other instances,
it was changed to black.
And then we go to the
point that it's either a W
or a C. You've effectively
erased an entire culture just
by changing the markings
on a piece of paper.
The census takers who came to
visit would look at someone
and just say oh, I think this
is what this person looks like,
and that's what I'm
going to call them.
And so, identity was lost.
I referred to the 1924
Racial Integrity Act,
which was the final blow
on negative culture.
Interesting enough,
there's something
in there called the Pocahontas
exception, which if you happen
to be a certain percentage
of Indian,
you could still claim
your European heritage.
But it was because you
connected back to Pocahontas.
So that's also part of
this identity issue.
But that is also something that
affects our Native population
because we are afraid to
admit we have some segments
of our native community, are
afraid to admit that we are made
up of multiple ethnic
or racial background.
And paper genocide led us down
that road, and we are happy now
that we're able to
reverse that cycle.
>> Joanne M. Braxton: Thank you.
Well, we're just
getting started here.
And each of us here on
this stage is involved
in some continuing
project or projects
that will serve the
commemoration of 1619.
We'll give you a few examples.
The Middle Passage Project is
compiling a digital database
and interactive map
and exhibition charting
the movements
and religious practices of
Weyanoke people, Native American
and other Native Americans,
as well as African
people in Virginia.
And this will include
the collection
of plant-based healing
practices, medicinal uses
of herbs and so forth.
This database will
expand opportunities
for collaborative
research by new
and emerging scholars
in the field.
So that's something
that's already underway
at William & Mary.
Trent, what else is
happening at William & Mary?
>> Robert Trent Vinson: Well at
William & Mary, November 2019,
the exact date is November 5th
through the 10th, November 5th
through the 10th, 2019, is
we're hosting a major conference
dealing with the implications
of 1619 going forward.
It is bringing together a group
of scholars and lay people.
The organization is called
the Association for the Study
of the Worldwide
African Diaspora.
Shorten that to ASWAD.
It's the major professional
organization for those
who study Africa and
the African diaspora.
We're all coming from all
over the world descending
on Williamsburg to William &
Mary to engage in reflections
on 1619 from Jamestown, but
also in the wider black world.
So that, mark your
calendars, November 5th
through the 10th, 2019.
>> Joanne M. Braxton: And we're
anticipating about 900 scholars.
Is that right?
>> Robert Trent Vinson:
About 900 scholars,
perhaps even 1,000
if you all show up.
>> Joanne M. Braxton: Cassandra,
what's happening
at Norfolk State?
>> Cassandra Newby-Alexander:
Norfolk State University
is going
to continue its 1619 Making
of America series
by having a summit.
This would be an
international opportunity for us
to livestream a conference,
a series of discussions,
by scholars throughout
the country
and throughout the world,
talking about exactly what we
talked about today, which is,
what happened beginning
in 1619, and how are we
where we are today if we trace
it back to that magical moment,
that important moment.
And by magical I don't mean
oh, this is just glorious.
But this magical important
moment in our history
where things changed, and
they changed much more rapidly
than we could ever
imagine today.
So, Norfolk State University
is going to be the host
to the 1619 Making
of America summit.
It is, we are doing
this in collaboration
with the 2019 Commemoration
Commission from Virginia,
American evolution, to really
help our nation to begin
to confront these issues.
We will have nationally-known
scholars, speakers
and others who will participate.
We will also have
breakout sessions
where we will livestream
this and connect
with not only other scholars
but with young people
throughout the country.
And so this will be
September 26th and 27th,
and on the 28th we will
have an actual tour
to take people to
these early sites.
So I hope you'll mark your
calendar and stay in our area
from September all the
way through November.
>> Robert Trent Vinson:
Hang out.
>> Cassandra Newby-Alexander:
To participate in all
of these wonderful events.
And also to help us this year
September 14th and 15th as well
as September 16th, we're
having a graphic novel contest
and competition also in concert
with the 2019 commemoration
commission.
Why? Because we want young
people who are interested,
who will read a graphic
novel to actually begin
to hear this story about
what actually began in 1619.
And it will be a contest in
which not only graphic artists
and novelists and illustrators
will be judging this contest,
but we would have
historians there looking
over the narratives to ensure
that this is accurate history.
That their storylines will
follow the correct line
so that we can get this story
out to the nation
and to the world.
>> Joanne M. Braxton: So,
it may be at Norfolk State.
It may be at William & Mary,
but you can be sure that all
of the folk on this
stage will be involved
in supporting the events
you've just heard about
and programs you've
just heard about.
So we're going to take a few
questions from the audience.
But then we're going to
come around at the end
to answer one last question
panel members, and I want them
to know what that question is
in advance while they're
fielding other questions.
And that is, what is the most
significant thing you would
like for others to take
away from today's symposium.
So we'll come back to that.
Questions.
Please.
>> Hi. Hi everybody.
Is this working?
>> Joanne Braxton:
Give her a hand.
Get that.
>> It's working there?
Okay, great.
Hi, my name is Nichelle
Smith, and I'm with USA Today.
I have a couple of questions
that might be really obvious
to some here in terms of
History, but I'm beginning
to see, as I'm reading
up on 2019 the use
of the phrase enslaved
Africans rather than slaves.
So I wanted you guys to explain
as I go forth for terminology
in terms of how to cover it
why you're using that phrase.
>> Joanne Braxton: This
folk were not born slaves.
They had to be made into slaves.
There are these places
along the coast,
especially in West Africa, and
I've seen quite a few of them.
And if you'd like to visit
them without going there,
you can go to the Middle
Passage Project page
on William & Mary
dot edu website,
and you can see Elmina
and Cape Coast.
Some of these folks were marched
mercilessly from the interior.
Maybe a third of the people
who started out on the journey
to the sea didn't make it.
Some would be yoked together.
People would be yoked
in cockles.
People whose health was not good
or was failing might be
left in the bush to die.
Small children might be
considered liabilities.
They might be left
in the bush to die.
But a day before, they may
simply have been taking a walk
in the woods.
You could have been
taking a walk
in the woods somewhere near
what is present day Accra today
with a loved one, and one of
you could be taken to Elmina.
One of you could be
taken to Cape Coast.
One of you would go to
a Portuguese territory.
an English territory.
And you have a first cousin
in Brazil while you're
in Jamestown.
So, so many times the
faces seem similar.
And when those people
left through those doors
of no return, some of which
were about 15 inches wide,
too narrow for you to go through
forward, just straight forward.
They would have to march
side-by-side to be able
to go through the door.
And most frequently, they
were taken out at night
because when they
would see the coast
of their nation falling away in
the distance in the daylight,
some of them would
just stop breathing.
And they refused to
be made into slaves.
And if you would
go to Elmina, also,
you would see there's a door.
There are two doors actually.
If you were to stand in the
Dutch reform chapel in Elmina,
which is directly over
the women's dungeon,
and you would look out,
you would see two doors.
They were for punishment.
One was for Europeans
who infringed upon some
crime while they were there.
And the others were for
Africans who refused
to be made into slaves.
Over that a door there is
a skull and crossbones.
And they would put as many as
four or five people int hat room
at a time, these Africans who
refused to be made into slaves.
And no one came out of
that door until everyone
in that room was dead.
You don't have to
believe my story.
You can check it out.
It is so utterly
and shockingly true.
And the photographs of those
locations are available
to you for viewing.
So, it's to acknowledge
the humanity of individuals
as human beings, with,
we would presume,
inalienably human rights.
>> Hello. Thank you,
Dr. Braxton.
It's been wonderful.
I'm a student at Montgomery
College under Vincent Intondi,
fantastic teacher of
African-American history.
Also, I volunteer in the Young
Reader's Center downstairs.
Yay. Yay, kids.
I was very interested to
hear you reference Nell Irvin
Painter's concept of Soul
Murder, and I hadn't heard
of the other scholar who
you said had developed --
>> Joanne M. Braxton:
Kelly Brown Douglas.
>> Kelly?
>> Joanne M. Braxton: Brown.
>> Brown Douglas.
>> Joanne M. Braxton: Douglas.
>> And how is she
elaborated on the concept?
>> Joanne M. Braxton:
She talks about it
in the use of specific cases.
I think she talks about people
who have been summarily murdered
or executed without
due process of law.
And she may have referred
specifically to the case
of Eleanor Bumpurs
as an example.
Eleanor Bumpurs, some of us will
recall, was an elderly woman
in New York City who didn't
have, had fallen $50 short
or something like
that on her rent.
And the police came.
There was a conflict,
and she ended up dead.
And this has happened
too many times.
So it's not just a question
of what happens to
the person's body.
It's a question of what
happens to their spirit.
And we have to think really
about the young people
who survive physically these
traumatic events but walk away
with invisible wounds that
are not unlike the wounds
that someone would
sustain on a battlefield.
The walking wounded.
Is that making sense?
But you will be able
to find more precise
and abundant references by
consulting her directly.
And the other panelists are
available to field questions
as well, so feel free to
direct questions toward them.
>> Hi, my name is Jama Kelvey
[phonetic], and I wanted
to just mention one thing
bout paper genocide.
I'm quite worried about
it coming up in 2020.
You referenced the census.
And there's a real danger
for all of us to be succumbed
or to have paper genocide
happen because the census is
in real danger, as I
think you all know.
So I wanted to mention that.
Professor Vinson,
congratulations
at William & Mary has its
first woman president.
>> Robert Trent Vinson: Yes.
>> Yes indeed.
[ Applause ]
Yes indeed.
Very happy, because she's coming
from my alma mater,
Smith College.
So I'm very happy about that.
I wanted to address my
question to you though.
I was really struck, this is
a statistic I had never heard
before about the low percentage
of the African enslaved people
who were taken to
Jamestown or North America
as opposed to South America.
And then you mention, of course,
that this American South became
the largest slaveholding society
in the world.
Can you, this is a very, a
question that you could write
and probably have written
thousands of books on, but why,
what conditions made
North America the place
for the largest slaveholding
society
as opposed to South America?
>> Robert Trent Vinson: Right.
That's a big broad question
that I can give you the short
answer is that slaveholders
in South America,
Central America
and the Caribbean
basically made a calculus
that it was cheaper simply
to keep importing
enslaved Africans.
And so literally, you know,
folk coming into the
Caribbean [inaudible]
since the average lifespan
after arriving in the Caribbean,
and these are people
in their prime,
their high teens, early 20s.
The average lifespan of
survival was seven years.
And we're talking about
a population that's
about two-thirds male.
So those two dynamics are
simply, it's cheaper just
to work them to death, work them
to death, work them to death,
and we'll just import
more, right.
And the gender imbalance meant
that there was a constant,
constant influx of
more people coming in.
So that was why the
numbers were so much higher.
So that was the center of the
gravity for the slave trade.
By contrast, North America was
really a type of backwater.
And so the way that Angela
and her fellow captors made it
to Jamestown was really an
accident of history, right.
They were on their way to the
epicenter, in this case, Mexico.
And because of those two ships,
they were rerouted, right.
And so ultimately, and then
the United States banned the
importation of enslaved
people in 1807,
even though there was some
illegal activity going
on as late as 1859,
short footnote.
But the dynamic there was
natural reproduction became the
preferred method if
you would, right.
And so in that time, we
have tremendous growth.
Right. In this way
too, we have to look
at the Louisiana Purchase as
an important event as well.
That doesn't happen without
the Haitian Revolution, right.
That's the first thing to say.
When Napoleon loses
Santa Mon [phonetic],
the largest slave-producing
island for them.
That becomes Haiti.
Essentially, he has less of a
need for French North America.
And he's trying to
finance his wars in Europe.
And so he sells what becomes
the Midwest United States
from Louisiana to
Canada for $15 million
in the Louisiana Purchase.
So Jefferson declares this as
an empire for liberty, right,
double the size of
the United States.
It really becomes an
empire for slavery
because there's a second
middle passage that happens
where a million people and
slave people move from states
like Virginia to places like
Louisiana, Mississippi, Alabama.
So doubling the size
of the United States also
doubled the size of slavery.
And so we had more
territory now, right.
So that is why we get the US
South becoming the large slave
society in world history.
Okay? You're welcome.
>> Thank you.
Hello. I'm very interested in
what you all have had to say
about collective trauma
in history and the need
to dispel false narratives.
And I was wondering what
any of you might have to say
about the possibility of
reparations playing a role
in that, not just
for African-Americans
but also potentially Native
Americans with removal
and if you feel that
could play a role,
how such a conversation
could even be begun.
>> Cassandra Newby-Alexander:
I'll take a stab at that one.
What is interesting to me is
whenever you hear the term
reparations, reparations
for formerly enslaved people
and their descendants,
the nation seems
to collectively just go
into trauma themselves.
America has a real problem
with acknowledging its role,
its guilt in sustaining even
our Constitution, sustaining
and perpetuating and
protecting slavery.
Most people are not taught
that the original
Constitution protected one piece
of property, enslaved people.
For the rights of those
who were the slaveholders.
Because the Fugitive Slave Act,
the three-fifths compromise,
all of these things that were
in the original Constitution
gave federal protection
to slavery.
And Virginia, of course,
was the largest state
that had the largest
population of enslave people.
In fact, for a long time,
Virginia had the
largest population.
That's kind of a duh, right,
because it was the first colony.
And all these people
that Dr. Vinson talked
about being transported to the
lower South, most of them were
from Virginia, and
yet, as thousands
of people were transported
beginning in the early 1900s
to the lower South, the
population in Virginia
of Africans
and African-Americans
sustained itself.
The reproduction was high
because of the kinds of crops
that were being produced,
the kinds of industries,
so much so that the
primary industry in Virginia
by the 1820s and 30s was
the domestic slave trade.
That is what Virginia made
most of this money from.
And so everything went into
creating more enslaved people
and making sure that
they survived to be part
of this domestic slave trade.
And so when we talk
about reparations,
a lot of people focus in on
what happened to enslaved people
and how their labor was
used for a long time.
But I actually argue that
reparations really should be
after 1865, after
the 13th Amendment,
after the 14th Amendment when
African-Americans whose rights
as human beings was now
federally recognized
that the states and
federal government continued
to deprive them of their
property, of their civil rights.
They began to redline them.
They began to make them pay
more money than white Americans
for their property,
for their schools,
even though their schools were
supposed to be equally funded,
or at least funded
by property taxes.
They weren't.
In the 1940s, the
Journal and Guide,
which was a black-owned
newspaper operating
out of Norfolk, Virginia,
published an expose showing
that Virginia systematically
took between 2
and $30,000 a year from all
of the counties and cities
in which African-Americans
were located.
This is money that
African-Americans were paying
in taxes to go to their schools,
and they were redirecting
that money to the white schools.
So we're not even talking about
paying somebody for labor.
We're talking about real
dollars that were supposed to go
to one thing, and they
were put to something else.
So reparations is
an important way
to start reinfusing our
communities and our society
with money that should be there,
should have been there
from the beginning.
I'm at Norfolk State University,
a historically black college,
or what they call black
college and university.
And Norfolk State University
was underfunded according
to the Virginia governmental
formula for 75 years.
For 75 years.
And Virginia settled that
underfunding for $10 million,
for 75 years of underfunding.
What can you do with
$10 million?
And I'm not talking about
$10 million in 1870 money.
I'm talking about $10
million in the latter part
of the 20th century dollars.
You can't even construct part
of a building with $10 million.
So reparations to me has been
seen when it comes to people
of color as a giveaway.
That everybody would get a dime.
But that is not what
reparations is all about.
It is restoring what was taken,
what was forcefully
illegally taken.
And how you restore is really,
really should be the
discussion line, not whether
or not it should be
restored but how.
And the way in which it can be
restored can help really enhance
our nation.
[ Applause ]
>> Joanne M. Braxton: So,
I've been given the high
sign by those above me.
And I'd like to close
by reflecting myself
on the question.
What is the most significant
thing you would like others
to take away from
today's symposium.
I would like you to reflect on
today's panel and the questions
that have just started
to surface as an opening
of moral space for
a conversation
about many kinds of repair.
Soul repair, material
reparations, and just a thought
about what it means
to be an American
and how we became Americans.
So this space is open now,
and we're going to do our best
to hold it open through 2019.
Please join us.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Travis Hensley: On behalf of
the Kluge Center and the Library
of Congress, I'd like to
thank all of our participants,
all of you for coming and, you
know, especially Dr. Braxton.
She's been a pleasure to have
with the center, and we're going
to be sad to see her go.
So once again, thank you.
[ Applause ]
So, now we have both a reception
for you all and then a display
of items from the Library
of Congress' collections.
You cannot take any food
or drink into the display.
My interns are well-trained.
So again, I'd just
like to thank you all
for coming, and please go enjoy.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.